foreign
wait no no you can't do this let me go
oh look matpat I definitely can
no no please I don't want to watch a
Cinematic Universe full of crappy Disney
rip-off horror movies
this is the world we're living in now
matpat and you only have one person to
blame for it hits you
you better believe it no
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that wants you to Maul that
subscribe button like a rabid teddy bear
that's looking for honey so if you guys
seen this ridiculous Winnie the Pooh
horror movie that just came out Winnie
the Pooh Blood and Honey yeah some indie
filmmakers have decided to take the
lovable Pooh Bear from the Hundred Acre
Wood and uh put a unique spin on the
idea to say the least reimagining the
story for children as a decidedly
adult-oriented slasher movie while the
film has been absolutely eviscerated by
both fans and critics the sheer novelty
of the idea of the adorable Pooh Bear
and his Pals going on a murderous
Rampage has earned a respectable 3.8
million dollars so far off of a budget
that was smaller than 100K it is enough
of a profit that the filmmakers have
already announced a sequel as well as
similar horror adaptations for other
Disney Classics like Bambi the Reckoning
and Peter Pan's Neverland nightmare all
of which will be part of a shared
Universe because of course they will be
now there's probably another theory in
here somewhere about how and why these
low budget horror movies get made and
how successful they are for the student
videos but for today I just wanted to
ask the simple question of how exactly
does this movie exist like legally how
did they get away with this thing well
Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey exists
because the Winnie the Pooh franchise no
longer belongs only to Disney it
actually belongs to you yes you sitting
at home without your pants on literally
you you see back the beginning of 2022
Winnie the Pooh entered the public
domain here in the United States meaning
that it's no longer protected by
copyright so now anyone can use these
characters and stories in practically
any way they want writing their own
sequels having poo in the friends in
their own franchises outside the
original work adapting them into
gratuitously violent horror movies and
Winnie the Pooh is not the only major
work that's on its way to being owned by
everyone is he loyal theorists the world
of entertainment is about to get very
interesting things are changing fast on
all fronts with a lot of very precious
and iconic stories and characters
entering the public domain with way more
coming out in the near future along with
the lovable Pooh Bear every single
Sherlock Holmes story entered the public
domain in 2023 massive pillars of pop
culture Superman and The Hobbit they're
set to enter in 2033 and if a decade is
too far away for you the granddaddy of
modern entertainment characters himself
Mickey Mouse is set to enter the public
domain in 2024. yeah next January has
got to be real uncomfortable for the
company that looks at their IP and
thinks
store my own time to win it's all fun
well hold on to your horses there
friendos there's a reason Walt's Empire
ain't too scared of Mickey's impending
release into public ownership during my
research looking into how exactly these
filmmakers got away with making this
off-brand horror Winnie the Pooh Murder
movie I discovered a horrible truth
about the way these sorts of laws work
and spoiler alert you will likely never
be able to use any of these iconic
characters owned by corporations like
Disney and WB and Universal and I
realized all of that just because of
this Winnie the Pooh slasher flick Blood
and Honey is far more than a ridiculous
attempt at making money for shock value
it's a peek into the terrible future for
these characters as their corporate
overlords try to keep their claws in
their IP and it all comes down to the
scariest thing of all legal loopholes
foreign
grab your buckets of honey and machetes
loyal theorists it's time to carve our
way into this mess before we get started
let me just call out this theory is only
going to be looking into and explaining
copyright law for the U.S that's uh not
to say that other countries and their
laws are unimportant it's more to say
that basically every country on Earth
has different laws regarding this sort
of thing and if we tried to hash out
every single rule in every single
country things would get very complex
very long and very boring in a hurry
additionally sometimes I feel like this
goes without saying but we here at Team
theorists are not lawyers this is not
legal advice we're just a bunch of nerds
with a lot of free time on our hands and
an obscene interest in who owns what in
the entertainment industry so to start
things off I feel like we need to be on
the same page here what even is a
copyright anyway sure you've heard the
term but it's kind of a weird nebulous
idea that can be slippery and difficult
to get a real grip on basically a
copyright is protection granted by law
for original works that you make it
ensures that anything original that you
write or make belongs only to you you
don't even have to publish it if you
make something original it's yours
automatically no matter what covers a
lot of different mediums books poetry
movies music even computer software and
architecture now being said a copyright
doesn't protect facts ideas or systems
if you want an example of what I mean
let's just look at the theorist channels
we don't own the idea or the format of a
theory about Games Film TV food style
whatever we can't copyright the concept
of a theory anyone can make their own
Theory videos here on YouTube and in
fact we outright encourage that it is
awesome to see but we do own a copyright
over the stuff like our exact thumbnail
the scripts that we write the videos
that we edit so anyone can go and make
their own theories they can even make
theories that spin off of our own but
they can't outright take our theories
and re-upload them as is to take a look
back at Winnie the Pooh the name the
characters within food the art the
designs the exact writings all of them
were protected by copyright but the idea
of a child being friends with a living
teddy bear is to Pig Rabbit doll Etc
going on adventures out in the woods
that isn't protected by the copyright
how then did these Indie filmmakers
manage to get the rights to use Winnie
the Pooh in this horror movie that
Disney definitely didn't authorize well
a copyright doesn't last forever and
when they expire The Works they
protected enter the public domain as I
mentioned at the top of the episode that
means that this work now belongs to the
public and anyone can do anything they'd
like with it the first number put on
copyright laws in the United States was
from the Copyright Act of 1790 which
gave authors 14 years of protection and
the ability to apply for an additional
14 years after that that period has
since been extended several times
throughout the centuries most recently
in 1998 with a copyright term extension
act currently a copyright lasts for the
entire lifetime of the author plus an
additional 70 years if the work was
created by a person if it was created by
a corporation the copyright lasts for
either 120 years after its creation or
95 years after its publication whichever
one comes first fun fact that copyright
term extension act from 1998 was
actually nicknamed the Mickey Mouse
protection act because Disney was one of
the primary companies lobbying hard to
get that thing passed I'm gonna choose
to believe that they offered everyone
who voted in favor of it a free trip to
Disney World so is Disney Just Gonna
roll into town and pay off the American
government to extend that copyright
again like they did before well no
probably not and for a few reasons first
of all with control of the U.S house
senate and White House split between
parties not a whole lot is getting done
in Washington these days secondly one of
those major political parties ain't too
big of a fan of the mouse these days so
if you think you're getting any of them
to back a bill that would directly
benefit the company better think again
lastly and probably most importantly
it's not 1998 anymore The Times They Are
a change in back then when the Internet
Was Young information sometimes took a
while to travel people couldn't easily
look up the entire world's worth of
information with a Wikipedia search
corporations like Disney putting all
this pressure on Congress to extend
copyright that could be done under the
table but now if Disney tried anything
shady like that Twitter Youtube Tumblr
and Tick Tock would be all over them in
a heartbeat we're talking about a
company that used to sue daycare centers
for having unauthorized murals of Mickey
and friends in the 80s but nowadays in
2020 when an elementary school screened
a legal copy of The Lion King as part of
a fundraiser Disney tried to find them
for it only for the internet to blow up
in a righteous Fury forcing the mouse to
apologize and CEO Bob Iger to personally
donate to that fundraiser instead the
power Dynamic has shifted so if Disney
either won't or can't extend the
copyright again is that it are we gonna
be seeing horror movie knockoffs of
Mickey's and Donald Ducks and Goofy's
popping up everywhere next year just
like we did with Winnie the Pooh is
everyone gonna own iconic characters
like Mickey Mouse and Superman
not exactly see when a work enters the
public domain that doesn't mean that
every iteration of everything in that
work also enters along with it it's only
the content in that original work as it
existed in that original work so looking
at Pooh Bear the only stuff that's
entered the public domain right now are
the depictions of Pooh piglet
Christopher Robin and all of their
friends from the very original 1926 book
by A.A Milne as they existed in that
1926 book and there's some pretty
significant stuff missing from that work
one big one who's red shirt it wasn't
added to the character until 1932 for an
RCA picture record a full six years
after the character debuted that means
you won't be clear to use a cute little
red shirt on your public domain Pooh
Bear Murder movie until January 1st
2028. this is actually why the poo in
Blood and Honey has a red flannel shirt
with overalls instead of a red shirt
that's three sizes too small in fact if
you watch the movie you might have
noticed one of our Fuzzy Friends missing
from the Hundred Acre Wood well Pooh
piglet Eeyore rabbit and Owl all make an
appearance Tigger was nowhere to be
found because he didn't debut until 1928
in the book the house at Pooh Corner so
he won't be in the public domain until
January 1st 2024 just in time for the
sequel to Blood and Honey won't even
surprise me Winnie the Pooh too the
bloody bouncing buddy this goes for
everything else that we've talked about
so far sure when stuff like The Hobbit
hits public domain you can use Bilbo and
Gandalf and Smog and Middle-earth in the
official Hobbit fan fiction that you've
been chipping away at or anything else
you want to write for that matter but
you can't reference any of this stuff
from Lord of the Rings or use any of the
iconic Middle Earth art beyond what was
published in 1937 for Superman you can
include the character in your stories
his Origins from Krypton as well as his
dual life as Clark Kent to the only
powers that he can have are super
strength being faster than a speeding
train and the ability to LEAP tall
buildings in a single bound all of the
stuff that he had when he debuted in
1938 no flight no heat vision no ice
breath no x-ray vision you know all
those things that make Superman a
Superman Mickey Mouse might be the
character that's actually changed the
most here though the original Mickey
from Steamboat Willie was exclusively
black and white he had a long tail his
eyes were just small pupils he was a
troublemaking boat pilot everything we
associate with Mickey today the red
pants the modern smiling face the
friendly personality the edgy leather
hoodie all of that came later and anyone
trying to use that stuff starting next
January when Steamboat Willie enters the
public domain they are sticking their
fingers into a legal mouse trap but even
with all that aside things are entering
the public domain it might just be
slower than everyone expects over the
next decade or so we'll still be able to
use some version of iconic characters
like Winnie the Pooh and Gandalf and
Superman and Mickey Mouse himself and
all of our own stuff just with a few
limitations and eventually we'll be able
to use all of the iconic parts of these
characters and their stories for
ourselves right well in theory in
copyright theory yes eventually but you
best hold on to your horses before you
get too excited their friend oh see
there's another side to this legal coin
that I don't see anyone addressing well
the copyright that these companies hold
for these older books and cartoons and
Comics are expiring soon the their
trademarks aren't and likely never will
wait I hear you asking what's the
difference between copyright and
trademark well trademarks and copyrights
are very similar things enough so that I
wouldn't be surprised if you got him
confused but they have very different
purposes while a copyright's meant to
protect someone's original creative work
like I explained above a trademark is
meant to protect their brand they're
designed to help a consumer identify the
origin of a product or service so they
know exactly what they're spending their
money on think of it like a seal of
quality for instance if you see that
iconic Disney logo on something the one
that looks like a signature with the D
that kind of looks like a g you know
immediately that this is a product
that's created and approved by the Walt
Disney Company that isn't just some
knockoff but the big twist here for
trademarks is that they don't expire as
long as someone is using their
trademarks amidst the proper paperwork
to renew them and defends the trademark
against anyone trying to use them then
they keep that trademark forever and
trademarks can cover a huge variety of
things including names words phrases
logos symbols designs but also things
that you wouldn't expect like colors
smell else sounds and you best believe
that companies are trying to take
advantage of that as much as they can if
you look up the word Superman on the
United States patent and trademark
office database you'll be given a ton of
results showing that DC Comics owns the
trademark for Superman spelled this way
in just about everything you can imagine
most of it makes sense like comic
magazines books concerning memorabilia
Motion Pictures and television programs
toy doll figures Etc but they also
grabbed it for things like lunch boxes
toothbrushes towels and blankets
advertising and Candy remember that
means that they're the only ones who can
release comics and books and movies and
toys just labeled as Superman so if you
want to use Superman and the title of
your product after it enters the public
domain you're gonna have to get real
creative with how you use Superman in
the title of pretty much anything that
you make ever maybe get your hyphens
ready and witness the rise of Superman
but see now that just looks weird
something else you'd probably never be
able to use the recognizable iconography
of Superman specifically his s Shield
Crest on his chest and the Superman logo
both of those things are trademark by DC
and you can bet that they are defending
them vigorously because those are key
parts of the Superman IP that they
outright own and that connects the brand
to DC when you see the shield DC wants
you to know that this is the official DC
product so yeah once Superman enters the
public domain you might be able to use
Superman in your story but if you have
to be that careful about the name logo
and crest of the character in any of the
products and marketing is it even worth
using him at that point the same goes
for all the other Heavy Hitters that
I've been talking about today Middle
Earth Enterprises and their parent
company owns the trademark for basically
any combination of the words the and
Hobbit that you can think of covering
everything from Toys to tea to cardboard
cutouts and drinking Steins so sure once
The Hobbit hits public domain maybe
Dungeons and Dragons can call their
halflings Hobbits again without getting
sued but good luck to anyone wanting to
start up their afternoon tea company
themed around and named after Hobbits
likewise Disney owns the trademark for
Winnie the Pooh regarding basically
everything that you can imagine as well
as some things you probably can't
imagine like gloves and Hosiery that one
is uh so oddly specific so anyone
wanting to use who in their public
domain horror film is going to have to
get creative and or specific with their
names and portrayals and you see that's
exactly what happened with blood and
honey there is a trademark registered
for the logo of Winnie the Pooh Blood
and Honey specifically for the
production and distribution of film and
television and for T-shirts because you
gotta get that merch game on baby I'm
assuming that the people behind this
film wanted to make sure that there
wouldn't be any knockoff merch available
in Hot Topic only the real deal knockoff
merch but you notice anything else funky
about this registration as compared to
that mountain of Disney owned trademarks
the registration for Blood and Honey is
super specific claiming quote the colors
red and light orange and the quote blood
red orange lettering of the title of
motion picture they're only trademarking
the logo and its color palette nothing
generic like the entire phrase Winnie
the Pooh across all children's Media or
whatever what's more notice any other
differences in the names I mean sure the
Blood and Honey Mark has that subtitle
but unlike all of the Disney marks it
also has dashes between Winnie The Who
that makes it just different enough just
stylized enough to help help him stand
out from anything Disney related
honestly if the purpose of trademarks is
to help customers identify the origin of
product the fact that Blood and Honey is
so stupidly violent and so obviously not
something Disney would authorize
probably protected these filmmakers more
than anything else now normally I think
that this is where we could wrap things
up we've done the whole hey this thing
you think you know actually isn't that
way and there's this other thing that'll
change your perspective on its stick but
there is an extra twist here loyal
theorists the fact I uncovered that
transforms this conversation about the
quirks of copyright law into a
conspiracy about these Mega corporations
twisting the rules to benefit them and
it all comes back to the mouse literally
throughout this entire Theory we've
touched on how Mickey Mouse is about to
enter the public domain how Disney's
delayed the inevitable for decades how
they won't be able to do it again and
all of that is still true likewise
everything we've said about Superman and
The Hobbit and Winnie the Pooh also
applies here Disney owns a ton of
trademarks around Mickey Mouse which
makes a lot of sense he's an integral
part of their brand so much so that
they've started incorporating him into
all sorts of branding within their
company but you see what I just said
right there that right there is the
genius 4D chess 1 billion IQ move that
these companies are starting to make
these companies understand how
trademarks work and they're starting to
weaponize them in an effort to shut down
public domain as we know it today I
started looking into all this for the
theory the fact that Disney appeared to
not be fighting to keep their Golden
Goose protected by the law honestly
shocked me more than anything else
Mickey Mouse is Disney and they want
everyone else to think so too so what
have they done well in 2007 they
redesigned their logo for their Flagship
animation company Walt Disney Animation
Studios these are the people who make
stuff like Frozen in Kanto Tangled all
the Disney fairy tale Heavy Hitters and
what was that redesign logo the literal
frames of Animation from the most iconic
part of Steamboat Willie Whistle and all
that logo you betcha it's trademarked
Disney found a way to get true permanent
control over the most important parts of
the first release of their most popular
character all of it while playing within
the bounds of the law so sure when
Steamboat Willie and Mickey sail down
the river into the public domain in
January of next year maybe you can
navigate your way through all of this
legal Minefield maybe you could figure
out a way to use Mickey as he first
appeared here in Steamboat Willie
without using the exact iconic frames
from this trademark logo will
transforming it all enough to be
distinct from Disney's brand maybe you
could have yourself a black and white
movie with a mischievous monochromatic
Mouse set on a boat whistling as he gets
up no good you know you put it that way
it actually sounds a whole lot like the
perfect setup for a horror movie and
thus everything circles back around to
Blood and Honey I wasn't kidding at the
top of this Theory when I said that the
true horror of this movie was the
copyright laws surrounding it because I
believe that this horror remake of
Winnie the Pooh is setting the precedent
for how we're gonna see many of these
beloved characters interpreted by other
artists as they enter the public domain
especially for characters like Pooh and
Mickey and Superman seriously these guys
are gonna look so different from what
we're used to seeing that they might as
well all be low budget b horror movies
or you know you could just take your
ideas and turn them into original Ip so
that way you can own those things for
yourself then again looking at the box
office performance for blood Blood and
Honey yeah no one's gonna do that feed
me the Nostalgia berries but hey if you
want even more insight into Shady legal
Shenanigans you should go check out our
brand new style Theory talking about the
Strange World of clothing copyrights if
a company has been accused of stealing a
copyrighted Clothing Design multiple
times over how are they still in
business how are they still able to get
away with it link to that video is on
screen right now I could not believe
some of the stuff I learned from that
one hope you enjoyed that video and as
always my friends I'll see you next week
until then remember it's all just a
theory a film Theory and cut